people around the new administration
economic advisors are saying that we can
grow our way out of this if we could get
GDP growth real GDP growth to three to
four percent we could actually grow our
way past the liability problem and there
is something an analogy in the private
sector with the US banks in the 80s when
they had that crisis in the Latin
American debt situation and they really
couldn't cover the liabilities they
extended the maturities but they were
allowed to earn their way out of that
building up reserves by making profits
elsewhere could we do that with the US
economy not now let me explain to you
why a necessary condition for economic
growth is that output per hour grows at
a rate probably close to two percent
we're now under 0.5 percent meaning we
it were worth essentially for the last
five years have been growing was
scarcely at all with respect to output
per hour but once you've got an output
for our forecast and you know what the
total level of the population or the
working force is you just multiply one
times the other the hours and the
productivity and you get what the GDP is
going to look like they're little
variations here and there but that's
fundamentally the issue if you don't get
output for our growth you will not get
the type of GDP growth which the people
who are talking about we can now grow
our way out of it and unless you change
the fact that we've got this 9 percent
average annual increase in entitlements
which is eating into the domestic
savings of the economy which in turn is
a critical issue which is required to
get capital investment going and capital
investment is the key element in
productivity growth so it's this
entitlement issue which nobody wants to
discuss the Democrats don't want to
discuss it the Republicans who actually
have been spending more
and faster rate than the Democrats in
the last 65 last half-century nobody
wants to touch it instead it's the third
rail of American politics if you're
running for office and you mention it
you lose and unless and until that issue
is addressed I don't see how will we get
the economy growing because we're
borrowing savings from abroad we're now
up to eight trillion dollar debt net for
the total system you can't keep doing
that and I doubt very much if we're
going to be able to do very much more
borrowing from abroad and if we can't do
that
and we don't have domestic savings
because it's being crowded out by
entitlements where do you go from there
and it's a nice idea to say well we'll
you know to build our way out of it good
luck so where do you go from there
because one of the biggest changes we've
seen since you first came to Washington
love these many years ago is the
leveraging up and first it was in
private leveraging both households and
companies and then since 2008 or so it
feels like we've taken that and put on
the public balance sheet both in this
country around the world with central
banks and with fiscal authorities is
there a limit to how far up we can
leverage our society
well the key issue is going to be to
what extent the money supply is growing
and the one thing the reason why I think
that stagflation inflation part is
relevant here is there are two forces
that are going on first
importantly is that the money supply
which had been growing at about 6%
annual rate very steadily earlier this
year tilted up and we're now close to
nine percent annual rate that's a
necessary but not a sufficient condition
to get the inflation rate going quickly
but we're also finding that the labor
force
is running out of extra workers the
unemployment right now is under five
percent you can't go very much lower
which means that the 150 to 200 thousand
increase in payrolls
a month it's not going to continue on
twitch we're running out of people so if
you have a situation where the issue is
getting to be an ever tighter labor
market then wages begin to move and
indeed they are already beginning to
move and when wages are moving and the
money supply is accelerating those are
the critical issues which engender
inflation they are on the move at the
moment I see no evidence and endeavor on
the part of either Republicans or the
Democrats or anybody else for that
matter willing to come to groups what
the issue is because it's politically a
hot potato